então boa tarde estou muito feliz aqui
de estar com vocês pensando é esse tema
de qual a universidade a gente quer
passar adiante para as próximas gerações
né
e quando a gente pensa nisso que
mensagem quase que a gente vai passar
aquele espaço a gente vai passar a gente
tem que olhar pros as mensagens que a
gente mesmo recebeu nessa gente aqui
nasceu e foi agora você nasce faz isso
faz aquilo ea gente mesmo está passando
uns para os outros e muitas vezes a
mensagem que a gente passa implícita uns
para os outros é sim ou não aqui é assim
ó vai dar certo vai dar certo vai lá vai
dar certo né
é só o mundo têm problemas mas é só você
casar só você tem uma carreira só você
fazer as coisas todas é isso pessoal uma
mensagem que é uma mensagem desonesta
sabe porque gera uma quantidade infinita
de pessoas que assim que dá errado assim
que elas começam a sofrer
elas acham que elas fizeram algo errado
então é como se a gente estivesse
vivendo uma epidemia de ansiedade por
exemplo
mas se você pergunta pra pessoa ela diz
eu sou ansiosa ela diz como se fosse só
ela né é uma injustiça isso aí a gente
trata os problemas que são coletivos de
modo individual então a gente disse para
a pessoa se ajustar para lá ir para um
psicólogo prega psiquiatra né
como uma pessoa está trabalhando 14
horas por dia
vamos pôr fazendo publicidade uma coisa
que ela nem acredita e a ela ela do s
dor na coluna e stress chega pro doutor
que a gente fala por meio do doutor como
a sociedade para ela aqui o seu remédio
se ajusta a gente não vai falar para
transformar sua vida inteira vamos mudar
a sociedade inteira
de modo que a gente consiga trabalhar -
todo mundo porque não adianta só uma
outra pessoa trabalha menos criar um
mundo inteiro pra gente curar sua doença
então é então a mensagem eu acho que a
gente deveria se a gente fosse um pouco
mais realista falar assim não tá dando
certo e não vai dar certo se a gente
seguir assim
então pra isso a gente precisa cada um
de nós aqui cientistas do nosso próprio
sofrimento porque se a gente não
se a gente não olha para o sofrimento a
gente fica pousado
não sei vocês que são jovens mas quando
tiver crescendo
a gente vai ficando pousado wilson
gustavo
a gente vai ficando super pousado porque
é o a pose de 2011 não está em contato
com o sofrimento a prova disso é que
quando uma pessoa entra em crise
cai a pose né então quando a gente entra
em contato com o nosso sofrimento com o
sofrimento das pessoas
a gente toca o mesmo chão a gente sair
do isolamento a gente se une todo mundo
aqui se a gente tocar o sofrimento a
gente está junto
imediatamente ea gente gera motivação
pessoal e gera energia como é que eu vou
ficar num mundo que precisa de tanta
coisa pra ser feito tanta gente
precisando de ajuda
como que eu vou ficar perdido sem
motivação né então falta contato com o
sofrimento falta tirar essa pose né
por exemplo vamos porque esses dias uma
pessoa lá em goiânia 1 foi um homem um
policial ele foi com a namorada na praça
de alimentação do shopping
pegou no meio de todo mundo atirou nela
e se matou em seguida
tem vídeo disco com sangue e enfim tudo
então quando você vê uma coisa dessa
você pode achar que é um caso específico
é um caso específico mas não é não é da
minha família mas se olhar família da
humanidade ele é meu irmão por exemplo
se eu olhar o espaço amplo da terra é a
minha casa então se o meu irmão matou a
namorada dele na minha casa que casa que
eu estou cultivando relações eu tô
cultivando que semente de controle ciúme
eu tô cultivando pra dar espaço para o
meu irmão fazer isso ali na esquina né
então essa eu gosto muito dessa frase
assim que até agora a gente tem
colecionado muitas soluções
mas a gente não sabe ainda qual é o
problema então especialmente agora que a
gente tá junto vem dos vários problemas
vocês vejam se a gente não tem uma
clareza do problema pode ser que a gente
passe dez anos para pôr uma solução que
não muda nada
um exemplo isso acontece mil
universitários políticos mas num nível
meio bobo assim a thing pessoal é assim
eu estou batendo cartão acho que meu
problema é trabalhar batendo cartão aí
eu queria uma empresa na época estava
estressado mas eu acho que eu sou o
comércio
em de viagem do mundo como o laptop só
que eu fiquei estressado também dá tão
certo empresa
então eu estava sofrendo não debater
capitão estava sofrendo de outras coisas
né então a gente precisaria ver os
verdadeiros problemas senão a gente abre
o site do ted
a gente encontra 35 mil problemas várias
pesquisas
a gente tá dormindo errado comendo
errado fazendo tudo errado e aí a gente
vai precisar fazer 35 mil soluções já
viram isso eu tenho que fazer 35 mil
coisa todo dia para poder ver melhor
então um é essa que o raio x das apostas
da humanidade pra para lidar com o
sofrimento é como se fosse assim isso
aqui onde a gente está apostando nosso
tempo né
a gente está apostando achando que é
aquilo que as soluções todas elas são
elas precisam ser externas a gente vai
regulando as várias coisas ajustando as
várias coisas e acaba isso sim
basicamente um monte de controle das
condições externas e que acontece a
gente aqui tá aqui querendo mudar o
mundo nós somos um exército de pessoas
que vão mudar o mundo mas se a gente
está tentando controlar todas essas
coisas
primeiro vocês já viram alguém que já
quebrou todas as coisas
a pessoa vai bem no trabalho do sr
melhor o corpo vai mal no casamento vai
vai bem no casamento vai mal no trabalho
então a gente é um exército de pessoas
tentando mudar o mundo mas um exército
de seres esbaforidos os exército de
seres ocupados demais a gente mal
consegue olhar para o outro se a gente
está focando tanto nisso não tem nenhum
problema e focar nisso mas ensinar toda
a história chama isso de felicidade
condicionada
então isso resulta nisso aqui ó a gente
muda de namoro sem transformar o ciúme a
gente muda de método de produtividade
sem nunca transformar atração demanda de
livros sobre o foco agora lançou um novo
mas nunca para o treino nosso foco
direto à demanda de empresa e não
transforma competição a gente muda
ansiolítico remédios em transformar a
ansiedade em demanda de um projeto
incrível sem mexer no alto centramento
muda de objeto não transforma pegou uma
onda de casa em transformar esta
situação então como é que a gente começa
a mudar esse foco então aqui essa a
minha fala que ofereça é uma fala assim
como é que a gente olha pra outra coisa
que não precisa
tanques externos que a gente já sabe que
tem que mudar a gente está aqui já
falando disso mas eu venho oferecer um
pouquinho dessa outra coisa essa
pergunta maravilhosa pra abrir essa
outra coisa o que você quer quando você
quer o que você quer
então você diz assim eu quero pós doc
que eu quero quando quero pós doc
aí eu quero e trabalhar em bora bora não
vamos são miguel dos milagres e que já
não foi uma praia maravilhosa que eu
quero eu quero ir pra são miguel dos
milagres a gente vai começar a olhar o
nosso mundo interno a gente vai começar
a ver que o que a gente quer
a cada momento a experiência interna
diante de tais coisas não é tais e tais
coisas se eu não faço isso eu fico refém
detalhes das coisas mas eu começo a
perceber que eu não quero as coisas mas
a experiência interna e comércio mansi
pa
nossa pergunta é maravilhosa maravilhosa
vocês vão ver que vocês fizeram essa
pergunta no casamento vão ter várias
ideias diferentes
tanto é que se você quiser se aquela
pessoa sem que essa pessoa faz alguma
coisa diferente e você começa a sofrer
você tem uma pessoa que é o que acontece
né a gente não quer bem as coisas
externas
outra pergunta que nos faz é muito assim
voltar pra ser outro aspecto interno é
onde nós realmente vemos esse pergunta
isso onde estão agora vocês acham que
estão na universidade das que estão em
cadeiras em átomos questão em sinapses
no cérebro então toda onde as pessoas se
apaixonam se deprimem onde acontece a
alegria com paixão felicidade onde
acontece o arrais mais profunda
desigualdade social a corrupção do
machismo dos e do racismo do preconceito
onde a gente vive pessoal não vi e não
pensasse na paciente não vive átomo
então qual é o nosso maior ponto cego
nosso maior ponto cego seja estudos
acadêmicos seja nas conversas do
dia-a-dia seja quando a gente olha para
a vida pra gente olha para a sociedade
nosso maior ponto cego é que a gente
ignora o nosso mundo interno nosso mundo
interno onde a gente vive o tempo
inteiro em separado do mundo externo a
vida vivida vivido em primeira pessoa
vocês vão ver quadro
não tem trabalho usando métodos em
primeira pessoa a pessoa investigando a
própria mente não o cérebro não os
comportamentos não há sociedade há
propriamente né então a maior marca
maior ponto cego é que a gente finge que
as pessoas não têm em mente que a pessoa
chega pra gente fala assim eu tô
adoecida do s
aí falei bom tomar o remédio vai fazer
tal coisa mas eu quase que não diga se
você tem uma mente você poderia
trabalhar com somente de não dizer se
uns para os outros diz assim vai lá faz
isso vai falar daquilo não muda isso
externamente
então quando a gente descobre que a
gente tem uma mente o mundo interno a
gente começa a ver que a nossa mente é o
que a gente leva para todos os lugares
que a gente vai se a gente leva uma
mente pedida a gente deixa todos lugares
perdidos entende que é um pouco assim
que um preço que não vai dar certo vou
dizer assim é um pouco assim eu vou mais
à frente se inscrever somente mas é
quando a gente percebe isso que a nossa
mente está presente o tempo inteiro a
gente percebe que a felicidade genuína
esse bem estar mais profundo ele não
vendo que tiramos recebemos do mundo ele
vem do que a gente cultiva e oferece não
vem das experiências que surjam os olhos
mas dos olhos que a gente leva as
experiências não vendo que o trabalho
nos dá esse papinho de trabalho com que
você ame a gente quer trabalhar com
energia minas e energia vem do que a
gente oferece para os outros então em
vez de fazer shop para descobrir o nosso
propósito deveria fazer um shopping para
descobrir seus efeitos o que só pode ser
feito ao redor do que as pessoas
precisam não vem das pessoas mas das
relações positivas que cultivamos
oferecemos aos outros então claro a
gente vai olhar para as nossas
qualidades mas a partir do que o mundo
precisa né
então a pergunta crucial aqui que eu vou
propor para vocês fazerem não importa o
que vocês estejam fazendo o que eu tenho
certeza que são coisas muito positivas
é para melhorar ainda mais a ação
deixaram mais ainda potente assim com
qual mente eu faço o que eu faço eu vou
participar numa reunião a reunião
maravilhosa vamos para a reunião de
transformação de conflitos mas com qual
mente estou indo entende que a gente não
mexer nisso
vai ser tudo mais difícil pessoalmente
vai se atrapalhar novamente vai ser
como como a gente quer fazer dieta mas
aí a gente mesmo se a bota né
é uma coisa meio assim a gente ignora
que a gente tem o mundo interno como
está nossa mente em geral não sei vocês
mas vou dar uma dica que descrever 3
problema só da nossa mente
novamente ela está desequilibrada então
isso em vários sentidos a primeira coisa
a gente não é capaz de relaxar está
tenso quase o tempo inteiro então a
gente precisa de caipirinha de massagem
sexo de várias coisas para poder fazer a
pride de cinco horas aqui não é em são
paulo de desgastante então se a gente
leva essa qualidade de tensão mesmo
sentido há uma coisa que a gente tem
conteúdo positivo a gente está estudando
coisas boas a gente faz aqui no tenso
pessoal e adoece a nossa mente reativa
eu vou fazer um experimento rápido aqui
por favor alguém grite a b ou c a b ou c
vejam esse uma mente reativa porque é
uma mente uma mente impotente passiva
diante das opções que são dadas
vocês poderiam ter falado 8 cheio doha
mas falaram a abril sentem extremamente
reativa pessoal é uma mente facilmente
manipulada entende realmente está
vendida
a gente sai nessa quarta somente no na
rua está vendido
qualquer grande propaganda corporação a
gente vai vai nos comprar fácil fácil
novamente é traída disse que a nossa
mente não consegue parar por três mais
do que três segundos alguns dizem 8 mas
na verdade fizeram um experimento é 33
segundos com as chances de a gente fazer
um pós doc simplesmente tudo é muito
difícil
socialmente a atração acontece assim a
gente começa uma conversa começa a
aprofundar as coletivamente uma conversa
vem a mídia internet a tv
se acontecer alguma coisa discutam a
gente começa a discutir outra coisa
acontecer uma coisa discutam
vocês vejam a gente tem o tempo inteiro
parece que tá começando do zero as
conversas pessoal que é absurdo e não
com uma profunda coletivamente de novo
de novo agora a gente tem que incluir de
novo né a
essa conversa muitas vezes mas a gente
ainda está começando do zero a kibon
quem está começando a usar mais né
- a distração ea nossa aqui para votar
acabou a bateria só precisa saber e
novamente ela é emocionalmente
independente então a gente precisa que
coisas aconteçam para nossa energia
subir então se aqui a palestra tá ruim
vocês vão o brilho dos olhos de vocês
vai baixando mas se a palestra fica
legal você tem um brilho dos olhos vêm
pra cima então como quando tudo desabar
ao redor quando a sociedade mais
precisar quando o casamento mais
precisar quando o trabalho mais precisar
nossa energia vai estar lá embaixo do
que a nossa e já está dependente das
coisas e eu ia divulgar onde mais a
gente precisa tocar neles a alta é
quando as coisas ao redor
a gente precisaria ter uma emancipação
onde teria tem uma autonomia de ânimo
diante da das aparências
então outra outro problema da nossa
mente
a gente tá muito sério pessoal a gente
não vê as coisas como brincadeiras
a gente compra muito fácil a realidade
das coisas parece tão sólido então a
gente entra aqui eu sou palestrante
vocês são um público super lestrange
entende vale isso é uma brincadeira
só que a gente entra muito rápido e aí o
professor universidade chega um
professor chega para o aluno e fala
assim
todo esse trabalho tem sete dias para
fazer o professor acha que ele vai sair
da universidade sendo aluno ele sai da
universidade vai ser namorado pai vai
ser trabalhador não vai ter sete dias
como aluno então a gente se confunde a
gente entra em bolhas e não percebe que
as pessoas não são as identidades que
elas são elas são muito mais entende
então como é que uma mente dessa ela
pode furar a burocracia novamente
facilmente não fica impotente para
brincar mais ver que as coisas não são
tão sólida quanto parece tudo montado
assim em igual isso aqui tudo montado
então por fim o terceiro terceira
problema da nossa mente que nos impede
em qualquer lugar que a gente esteja é
que a gente está muito mas muito mas
muito olhando só para o próprio umbigo
a gente tem relações utilitários as
pessoas entram na
a vida de acordo com o que elas podem
nos dá a gente a gente fala em termos de
carreira de sucesso pessoal
a gente é quase como assim a gente olha
pra trás e vejo que ela assim eu
participei de uma universidade com
muitos seres sendo formados e muitos
professores e os meus pais bancando e
toda uma coisa acontecendo não a gente
diz assim eu me formei em administração
não é verdade não é verdade isso é um
ato central momento entendi quando a
gente tá autocentrado a gente está numa
posição assim em que a gente não tá
olhando para os outros a gente não tá
olhando o mundo dos outros entende a
gente deveria entender que a agente está
todo mundo no mesmo barco ea gente
precisaria então incluir todo mundo no
nosso coração sejam como seria a mente
de vocês no coração de vocês em ninguém
de fora entende sem gerar inimigos sem a
noção de que tem alguém que o que é um
inimigo o inimigo um parceiro com
dificuldades são as mesmas dificuldades
e tem um conselho que eu daria
se eu encontrasse assim alguém primeiro
ano de faculdade
eu chegaria pra pessoa fazia de coração
se você quer ser útil em qualquer lugar
que você for eu sei que é um emprego mas
da vida uma coisa assim não parar nunca
de trabalho que você precisa fazer não é
habilidade pessoal não é uma nova
habilidade não novo ajuste de uma
terminar dinho aqui uma turbina dele que
a gente precisa fazer tem uma mente
mente que ela é capaz de direcionar a
própria atenção e manter a própria
energia
quando tudo a fundo a gente mantenha a
autonomia de energia tem uma mente que
que fura as bolhas vai além das
identidades sorrir para as construções
todas e não precisa não tem nada o tempo
inteiro sente pará que a gente vai
perceber que não tem o mundo o mundo que
a gente constrói momento o momento mas
na humanidade terá bom para o cadê o
mundo
a gente não está nem desconstruir essa
gente começar a construir outra coisa
então eu diria para ele que basicamente
ele age com a motivação de beneficiar
todos os seres se entrar num lugar assim
ele vira líder porque ele mantém a
energia dele era todo mundo as pessoas
vão elas 60 em vistas por ele entende
eu diria que esse compreensão do mundo
interna capaz de mudar todos os âmbitos
do jornalismo turismo administração
economia todos os âmbitos mudam quando a
gente olha para o mundo interno
então o que a gente precisa fazer para
isso a gente é muito teórico a gente já
aprendi dentro muito legal aquela
palestra que precisaria para olhem para
a vida de vocês desde ser nasceram
quando eles pararam
já para encontrar esse lugar de onde
outro movimento é possível para
encontrar esse lugar de onde a compaixão
é possível a gente precisa parar e
quando a gente para a gente convida os
outros a pararem e aí que vai acontecer
a gente vai começar a sentar mais em
roda que é o que já está acontecendo a
gente senta e roda e diz assim como é
que a gente está nascendo como é que a
gente está morrendo como é que a gente
está casando como é que a gente está se
relacionando
como que a gente quer viver entendi
então com isso sabendo que a gente está
fazendo isso eu agradeço
me sinto junto de vocês na obrigado
[Aplausos]